طوق امني كثيف هنا قرب هذه المحطه الواقعه
في منطقه اريل شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله
بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي طعن فلسطيني
المدنيين ليتسبب في مقتل ثلاثه اسرائيليين
بعد عمليه الطعن هرب بسياره الى هذا
الطريق السريع ليتسبب في حادث سير ويدهس
اسرائيليا اخر عند خروجه من السياره اطلق
الجيش الاسرائيلي النار عليه تقع مستوطنه
بين مدينتين بالاسوره وتعتبر من اكبر
الكتل الاستيطانيه في الاراضي المحتله
التي تشهد الصعيد منذ مارس الماضي عندما
بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي بشان عمليات دهم
واقتحام شبه يوميا بعدها جمال يستهدفت
اسرائيليين يوم الاثنين الماضي قتلت القوه
الاسرائيليه شابه فلسطينيه بعد ما اقتربت
بسيارتها بسرعه من الجنود بحسب الجيش
الاسرائيلي
نفذ الهجوم في منطقه اريل قبل ساعات فقط
على اداء اعضاء الكنيسه الاسرائيليه
اليمين الدستوريه فيما يعمل زعيم اليمين
بنيامين نتنياهو على تشكيل حكومه جديده
بالتحالف مع احزاب اليمنيه متطرفه